épouse d'un geste et on étend sur une
chaise et owen a réussi en plein de
spectacles à se faire mal aux genoux et
c'est arrivé ça arrive il s'en fout la
question oui mais mais je me dis oui
marque un panier de vie me suis envoyé
quoi en tout cas bon rétablissement et
ouais
on s'ennuie au maximum ans et demi au
pire ont droit on s'est mis devant les
toilettes du train qui sentent le cacao
est d'accord ou pas j'ai pas mais j'ai
pas resté assez longtemps
vous voulez vraiment l'intégralité des
sans logis baby loup raconte annie au
nom à une salle de muscu diouf qui a
tout ce qu'il faut et je m'entraîne
direct direct frère s'est pas risqué à
l'appareil
l'athée à 106 60 kg s'est soudainement
la victoire mais son [ __ ] les
conditions ça c'est la machine pour les
moines qui s'entraînent à tirer les
cloches
c'est un favori pour des gens qui ont
des moins chers ils voient pas le
spectacle sous une bâche
ils ont tous le sont
j'ai vu comment j'ai l'air de marcher
quoi dounia public
à temps normal on va passer des
reclassements introduit voilà comme ça
tout s'est bien repris merci bonjour je
suis une luciole des cheveux
parfaitement nourrit de la racine
jusqu'à la pointe 100% curly 100% bouclé
à 360 degrés
c'est un ballon dirigeable presque nazis
c'est pas nazi mais presque
j'ai fait une petite pause pour un
spectacle pendant une durée de jeu pas
de tente a répété pour le club par
exemple apple toi tu sais ce qu'elle
veut et ça lui va d'un cadeau pour moi
attend on va les voir ça à temps et des
vipères là dedans vivez ou pas
c'est un cadeau d'accord d'accord ça
fait super plaisir c'est un très beau
collages montages hyper mignon tiens
l'homme kaka à mon chargeur yes man on
man c'est mon chargeur fois alors je
sais mon chargeur c'est sûr ben regarde
ce qui est écrit dessus d'envoyer écrit
gérard est alors gérée par décrire le
prénom gérard se met à faire j'ai pas
faire ça j'hallucine
incroyable ce mec incroyable aucun
respect des équipes des gens voilà je
suis à l'hôtel j'ai dormi cette nuit
quand même temps 0 secondes 0 secondes
je fais une grosse nuit blanche ce soir
je jouais devant trois mille deux cents
personnes à rennes voilà il ya beaucoup
de pression de ce 13 d'angoise de
fatigue quand on prépare sa bonne foi à
vendre sur ça ne me dit est ce que je
vais arriver et ce que je vais assurer
j'espère qu'il va pas vendre et où je
faire attendez je vais tomber dans les
pommes
bonsoir
quant aux tchèques
maintenant je vais dire une phrase à la
con que toute ma jeunesse j'ai entendu
dans des émissions à la télé et
qu'aujourd'hui je pense vraiment parce
qu'elle est vrai même si tu es au bout
de ta vie physiquement et mentalement
quand tu vois 5000 personnes s'est
déplacée pour toi rires se lever et
applaudir
ça donne un courage mon gars est une
force qui prend imbattable
arrêtez les placements merde je suis pas
venu en tant que mobistar
je suis venu en tant que jean claude
jean claude c'est jean claude van damme
c'est mon prénom tu as compris je venu
parler avec le coeur et quand j'ai parlé
avec le coeur c'est aussi un peu avec la
bouche si je parle pas avec la bouche ça
veut dire que mu et si je suis muet je
suis plus une movistar j'adore la vie